hey Jen what are we doing today girl
basically stuff going on a hike well
it's hot
why are you walking so fast we can use
done walking at the speed of my legs
which is slow doggy
[Music]
I gotta get calling me you know bow
that was a great hike we have very
successful night but now we're heading
to get some peanut butter cookies for
Jordyn he's about to hit 10 million
subscribers on YouTube so to celebrate
getting him favorite pokeballs I didn't
get him a little cake I think maybe
it'll say happy 10 mil
your little hot dogs and Sun look at
this watermelon jeepers cake I love this
place ten there's no beer oh no Forks or
handle we did you break it off that good
all right over there hiding behind a
knot oh yeah oh yeah well good thank you
yes look we don't have to break up the
six drinks and have the best and on our
say party celebration change look
victimís plate and then I'm gonna I'm
gonna um yeah to the third Street and
I'm gonna go get a nice little light
glaze on my hair because I always wait
until the last minute to make hair
appointments and she can never take me
so usually I'll just go in and get a
nice little glaze to make it a little
bit darker and I can hold me off until I
can actually make an appointment hey
doggy I love you do you know that it's
almost your 2-year adoption date when we
adopted you again
[Music]
great job you gotta get the b-roll Jetta
gotta get to be rose uh-oh this is a
b-roll this is this is this a role
[Music]
timing
yeah great time to go bring some games I
really wanted to bring this game to here
is a problem
Jenna well you know what the problem is
so this game copyright Oh Milly boys
weren't even oh they're very boring
yeah Matt was born in what 90s no 92 I
guess Jordan was as well right Matt said
like 40 minutes ago that he was going to
be here in 10 minutes and now it's 40
minutes later and he said he's going to
be 11 minutes he said 10 minutes at 6:21
642 it's up guys good day today yeah the
great thing did you bring you know
having a good day I got in the car
weird what time for time to the start
enjoy a good day and then two women into
the car look what happened yeah if you
weren't a liar you know how come why
I'll cook you okay Jordan we got you a
present
yeah it didn't get any better yeah but
you can't put sparkles on it we're
partners okay I can't amazing reselling
sparkles you didn't have to take it
y'all really wait I'm showing her that
part that part is here on the plate a
minute
a minute there's more I didn't have them
at the last party I had no and I felt so
bad about it
please they're unbelievable I'm gonna
happen right now in camera go ahead so
much bigger than I remember it well you
know I'll keep that it
prefer peanut butter family selling
cookies it's like a Nutter Butter cookie
if that makes sense territory i won
and if somebody said they changed the
recipe oh it's good
listen it is an Aston Martin BB 11
leaving v8 what about the $1,000
um yeah is it like a gray it's like it's
a white I don't know if you guys I love
the white
it's a good white it's like a pearl
fryar's get a wrap
can you heart it don't want me to talk
to you I can yeah a mile now man dad
makes is last by the wall I'm kidding
let me tell man yeah this is we never
here is first of all people you know now
you can go back there because Maddie is
not allowed to sit in front seats is
dangerous is that really there yes
because you can get it by the airbag and
die sure I like your winch up one
morning oh yeah cool it's pretty cool
that's the showstopper for that so
apparently this game of life is not a
big risk for a lot more players so this
my my babies explicitly like that you
could have it I read online it said two
to eight players
well this one isn't I think we're
probably going to run into problems
John full of problems already
well trauma presidents don't release the
song it was a good day in 1993 I knew it
I knew you would know it good job man
good job
dick you know that one I didn't either
but I knew you would oh you guys know
one more format jay-z's hard-knock life
ghetto anthem samples of songs from
which music manatees yep right or I feel
like everyone knows that everyone knows
that their hit me was a certain one
questions
[Music]
9si so stop walking
I take us nowhere I phoneme you're
vlogging honey blah you don't blogging
or your stream of entertainment for
three days give me a break
today I'm wearing a brand new video they
travel tonight welcome to what if I move
in if you just Kimmy you're born you're
up you're not my dad you know I don't
know now you're a little bit a lot of it
this is real life then I'm really just
getting by fast okay is it my turn now
yeah I thought whoa no that no happy ten
million subs what are you gonna do oh
I'm going to get Oh we cooking a white
or we have finished your like yeah okay
okay but that's what we're going to do
so I understand my life it's an
easy game this is about that okay Oh
half an actual hog we keep an actual way
I can see you're not honey
from who Thank You me $20,000 revived
because I have a college degree as a
scientist
all right so here's we're going to do
next time play this game how do I spend
our young life huh but I have no house
no kids no husband I've just in your
loans all my money loving it
[Music]
me matter for that dance oh that's not
half the keel okay here it is with the
overall feeling that there you go
are you shuffling shuffling and okay
just if you don't know yeah are you all
together now yeah no okay all right
power cause we got to make fire I got it
on the ultimate Wow and then you can
[Music]
[Applause]
turn myself I'm so hot now you see how
people like really mad installs up with
sparklers I wanna get close to that for
a photo
hey hey over here I owe you that's good
that's great
let's get sister to me what about man
nothing what is that get that this isn't
me I just get it
yeah came and we saw oh this is a
forever loop um well there's a great
blog I'll see you guys tomorrow bye
[Music]